what supplement is good for a person who is recovering from a heart attack?
So a heart attack is kind of we were talking about before where you have an ischemic
blockage of nutrition, oxygen, to cardiac tissue and you have to go, well why? So it's easy to go
let's leave cholesterol, you apply cholesterol, you apply cholesterol, you have cholesterol,
pack placket. But this is not always true. First of all, if you do have elevated cholesterol,
you have to look at liver function. You might have elevated, you might have cholesterol placket,
and not have high cholesterol, because you have damage to the arteries, because you had high
colon cystine levels for a period of time. You may have an ischemic attack because of what I said
before you actually have a deficiency in delta topotry at all. So you have a contraction of
your smooth muscle under the endothelial layer, but that's, it was just a ischemic attack because
of a contraction of that, that's not a permanent contraction, that's just damaging the blood flow
for a very short period of time. So there's a lot of reasons why. So again, with any treating,
anything you have to try to treat the reason why. So you got to figure that out. But nutrition for
somebody post heart attack, giving them cardiac tissue can be helpful to rebuild,
function. There is a product from biotics called cytosine H that is cardiac tissue that is good
for the heart itself. Looking at taking a full spectra vitamin E, we use that for cancer patients
that have private levels of product called ACOP E, that has the delta topotry at all in it,
and then addressing the reason why by addressing either lipid issues or endothelial damage issues,
or chronic undiagnosed H-pi-lori, or undiagnosed Lyme, undiagnosed heavy metal toxicity, those are the
three most common things that could damage endothelial cells and damage cause contraction of the
smooth muscles and contact blood pressure.